[Music]
all right today's question comes from
caitlin in colorado
caitlin says my ques my husband and i
are on baby steps four and six our
children's college funding is already
covered through my husband's gi bill we
paid off a hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars in 27 months while
working six jobs between the two of us
wow
while that feels great the problem is
i'm exhausted well no kidding yeah i'm
tired of working 70 hours a week and i
don't want to miss out on this time with
my kids i see in the everydollar app
what the extra income can do for family
vacations buying the things we put on
hold in baby step 2 and paying off the
house so i feel like i have to keep up
this crazy pace
how do i change my mindset from the
hustle and grind to get the debt done to
this is a crock pot in the rhythm of
life so i can finally enjoy what we're
working for for so long
man that's a
that's a question about identity that we
get a lot dave yeah how do i how do i
turn the gazelle off how do i let the
gazelle just rest and start grazing
again yeah when you finish your baby
step three and you've got your emergency
fund in place we tell you to change from
a gazelle intensity just to
intentionality just being doing things
on purpose so
here's what's new
what will never be the same because
you've changed the shape of your brain
permanently
what will never be the same is is that
you will never again look at the every
dollar budgeting app and not think oh i
could do this
i can do that i can do this you're
always going to have that thought
because you've retrained your brain to
actually pay attention instead of
letting this happen to you you're
happening to it
and so that's great news
and and you've identified what the
problem is you're tired
and so
you know you look at the every dollar
app and you go well i'm not gonna be
working as much and so we won't be able
to do this and this and this and this
but now you're doing it on purpose yeah
and that's fine yeah
i i like to there's a there's a
three-pronged decision making matrix
here you go practice curious and facts
i want you to
practice working fewer hours and then i
want you to feel how uncomfortable that
is and be curious with yourself why is
it why is it feel so uncomfortable right
now that i want to hang out with my kids
instead of going to deliver pizzas
tonight
and then i want you to sit down with the
data your body's gonna be telling you we
gotta keep rustling we gotta keep
running what are the facts the facts are
you paid your debt off
you're okay
and you're gonna slowly practice
retraining your body that you're not in
danger anymore and now it's about how
much fun can you have and like they've
said be intentional about your life
and i
i
i some folks dave i just i've just come
to understand some folks and you maybe
like to hit a light switch just off
i'm good i saved up my money and i'm
gonna do this thing
um i've found my wife's that way
we got the money we're good and i keep
thinking all right but what about this
what about this and so i got to practice
let's lean into it practice and then i
get better and better at it and then i
quit thinking about it after a while
so here's what happens
your nervous system resets right
and so you're driving 30 miles an hour
for a year
and then you step on the gas
and your heart rate changes your stomach
comes up in your throat adrenaline is
released and you're doing 90.
and then you set the cruise on 90 and
you ride along about two hours on 90.
then
you reset the cruise down to 55
and you feel like a turtle it's like
you're walking you feel like a turtle
you're like what happened yes i i
thought you know but at first 90 blows
your mind right but then you reset and
you drop back down to 55 after you've
got your nervous system reset at 90 then
it just feels like this is a crawl and
you're still not at 30. well you're
double you're almost 2x what you were
and here's the here's the demon here
your body gets addicted to yup the
cortisol and adrenaline that gets
released at 90. it begins to beg you go
back to 90. we feel we get we get that
that drug hit at 90. and you got to
retrain your brain that you know and
what's worse than that is 90 90 won't
deliver it anymore you got to go 110.
because you got you once you get
associated with that you've got to go on
up again and so you just have to force
yourself to go oh my god this you know
because when those white lines are
coming at you like
and then they're coming at you like dink
think it feels like you're dying it's
like the world's passing you about i'm
just are we crawling here
are we ever going to get there yeah you
know and but your what your nervous
system resets and it does it in any area
of your life once you've handled here's
another example okay i talked to people
that they you know they made 60 000
their whole life and then they start
making a hundred thousand dollars
and they make a hundred thousand dollars
for ten years and they lose their job
and uh they get a new job making 60. i
say well you're not going to keep making
60 because your brain is reset your
nervous system is set at 100 now you're
going to gravitate the gravitational
pull is going to pull you back to the
hunter but you've never been there
before the first time up that hill is a
steep climb yeah but it it's like
rolling down the hill to get there the
second time because you're you're
everything about you your way your mind
works is set on a hundred thousand now
yeah
it just changes everything yeah and you
can't go back you don't you know once
you've stretched you can't go back so
you're going to experience when you turn
this down
the feeling of you've gone from 90 to 55
but or 60 but that's still twice as fast
as you used to be going so you're fine
and what most people go wrong is they
feel that downshift
and then they try to hide from it they
try to they numb it they they get into
all kind of crazy addictions because
they feel like they're going too slow
they're going too fast and that's why i
want someone be curious about it go oh
yeah we're going 60 and what's the data
the data is we're going 2x what we used
to be
the other speed wasn't sustainable it
was just for a season we had to get out
of that yeah you're gonna get arrested
yeah or you're gonna crash your car or
your engine's gonna melt down right and
now let's be curious about it and we're
gonna practice and then 60 is going to
be a great cruising speed for the rest
of your life yeah yeah we'll be just
fine you have some more seasons at 90
and some of 40 but it's life you can
spike up if you want to spike up again
if you need to but you know it's not
sustainable you're exhausted yeah you're
exhausted yeah and you need your your
brain is telling you your emotions your
body your fatigue levels talking to you
and so listen yeah listen
and there's nothing wrong with that
everything you're doing is right
everything you're doing is normal the
beautiful thing though is
you now know what 90 feels like yeah
and so
it's no longer a theory for you
and there will come a moment when you
have to go 90 again and you will you'll
say
i can do it yeah and
i've had to do that after covet you know
i've got to kick my hours and the work
productivity that is you know i i'd
slowed back and
but i'm right back up where i was yeah
because there's some you know stuff
happening at ramsey and i got to be back
in the saddle and here i am so here we
go baby you know and i'm back on the
stage i'm back in the
media and back in writing books what
what do we got to do we get you know
because this is what it takes to go
right now but it's not for everything
not for everything
it really wasn't hard to get back there
either yeah i know it's part of and
that's the thing is part of me like just
give me an excuse to go 90s
and hey uh i want caitlyn i want you and
your husband you'll go celebrate you
paid up make it have a marker
like a thousand dollars
175 000 years 27 months go go have a
party mark the moment and then say
what's next don't just continue into the
trip and drive